let's welcome to the show GAD and kill
him a lot is about science everybody
that's right oh he said Elmo I said oh
my leg
yeah there's a whole debate about my
name there is right well GAD is Jeff Oh
cause you got no one calls you Brad I'm
happy to see you Jim good to see you too
but I see you only at night yeah Emily
at the Comedy Store
yeah at night it is a weird relationship
you build up with comedians like you
just walk in and you just kind of know
each other but then you realize we've
never spent any time together outside of
that and more than that I cannot imagine
you during the day I don't know why
because I'm creepy and I'm [ __ ] I'm
insect-like yeah and the light there's
too much light normally it's dark when I
see you it's dark
yes uncomfortable isn't it you just
don't see them as a productive member of
society and then gentlemen stuff happens
during the day like people who
contribute yeah that's not Jim no that's
funny it's like when you meet your
neighbor you're into vacation someplace
very far from home and you meet your
neighbor you feel you know him but he
don't know him right it's weird cuz you
see you say then there's nothing nothing
could you see them out of your
comfortable location right like seeing
your boss in a store see when you're
kidding you see your teacher like in the
supermarket you're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing here you know I mean like
yeah yeah yeah or at the pool the
swimming pool with the bathing suits
right yeah yeah it's impossible you know
like I shouldn't be exposed to this and
you're starting your tour to get is
really funny you you're it's called oh
my god US tour begins January 19th in
Denver so go to his website which is get
el mala al la e el mal eh it's okay you
know I'm not good
I know the people gotta know how to get
to it you want by the way at the cellar
every night the hosts they ask me how do
you say your name so I tell them one
second before they go onstage and they
screw up the my name every time every
time does that drive you crazy that like
you've packed out like arenas yeah and
then you come here and the guy at the
seller doesn't know how to pronounce
your name no the guy here guys at the
security do you know like me in really
yeah why would they say I don't know I
they said are you sure we don't have
your name how do you say your last name
I'm sorry show me your ID
that never happens in friends but it's
very humbling I like that
we were talking yeah you did you moved
here yeah that's crazy because we were
talking before you came in about how
that like ego builds up and when you
feel like you're not getting treated the
way you're supposed to be treated like
you can go into a rage very easily and I
will I would imagine that for you like
the these instances where in not just
France but many other countries yeah
you'd be treated like an a-list
celebrity you come here and they're like
yeah your name's not in the system so I
don't think you're I don't think you
should I study here that like that you
do yeah like that oh no not with girls I
mean with girls it's it's a problem you
know
it's the thing I like I was in LA a few
weeks ago I was in a bar and I was
talking to a girl American girl and she
was not very interested and then a bunch
of French people walked in the bar they
asked me for pictures and autographs and
she got so interested yeah she came back
to me and she said can I buy you a drink
oh really
but is that great don't like a lot of
people would go see you should show her
not do but I said no [ __ ] it I'll take
it we're gonna seal this deal now that's
good yeah perfect you know I need that I
need it because I physically I don't
have a whole lot to go on so they're
never gonna look at me and going wow so
it's always like whatever it is that
gets you in the door is all that matters
not yes yeah I think the thing is the
challenge and to start over is really
interesting for me to personal think
it's not only about stand-up it's just
starting over you know going to the
cellar as Jim said you know every night
trying bits in English struggling with
the language trying to make people laugh
earning those laugh because they don't
know me they have no idea and by the way
them but when when when some French
people come to the cellar it's it's okay
but I'm not that happy because you know
I'm going to do no no I'm like no please
let me just in earned those let me make
those American laugh but that's gonna
say it's very very different to to try
to get laughs now because part of it is
that you go onstage in front of an
audience that knows who you are and
they're just excited to see you so
they're ready to laugh and they're ready
fine and but when you go in front of
audience there's no who you are you
don't you haven't had that in years
no but okay you know it's the same thing
I mean you you you you know Jim when
some big names show up at the cellar
Chris Rock louis c.k Jerry Seinfeld when
they go on stage the first 30 seconds
it's it's a madness in the room but no
matter
who you are and how famous right after
the 30 seconds if you don't give them
it's on you yeah that's and even even
more more how you say sorry rude with
you if you're not doing good if you're
if you're gay of expectation of course
yes Chris Rock always has a very funny
line he'll meet the second he walks on
he's like lower your expectations and it
gets a laugh and then he kind of just
tells him he's going out of his notebook
but yeah I know what you're saying like
you you you don't you're so famous in a
lot of other places that you wanted to
come here and just and like just see
okay let me see what my stuff does here
the fact you're doing another language
is amazing to me yeah and also learning
to be honest with you I'm watching those
guys watching them working and trying
bits and and bombing sometimes and
redoing it again and this is a new total
new experience to me you know yeah and
obviously you don't do that for money
because as you know this is not where
people make money in crimes
you don't do it for fame or glory and
because for really because that's my
I've been doing stand-up for 22 years
now that's funny the other day one of my
good friends came to the cellar I said
oh only one year and you do stand-up I
said no oh one year in New York but I've
been doing this for 22 years all over
Europe
yeah that's why did you move to New York
I think it was such a ballsy move like I
would never leave my company because I
felt Trump was going to be elected I
knew guys the country was gonna be
something sexy or I knew it you were the
one guy who is like if Trump gets
elected I'm moving to the US right in
France and leaving cannulas in the US
yeah I got to be a part of this we're
gonna be great again yeah great I
thought it was great already great and
no exhibit II that's great that's good
no I think it's the challenge really to
the challenge I love my life in Paris
and I have my family and everything but
you know I need this challenge I want to
do stand-up we don't have clubs in
France that's was gonna ask what the
what the comedy industry is like in
France and Europe you know the comedy
world is so different we have one comedy
club created by a very famous comedian
named Jamel the boos and he did this and
this is the only place where comedians
can go and work out some material so
it's a very competitive there to get on
yeah yeah but they have shows even even
if they're not big names they have their
own shows an hour an hour and 30 minutes
ah but let to be honest with you I think
there are more here oh [ __ ] the word in
English
Carol is going to tell me eggsy Shaun
Wow she doesn't demand a man the
demanding the audience here the audience
is more demanding like that yeah I like
they're more likely to really let you
know if you're not doing well here then
there's less politeness and especially
here in New York and especially at this
hour some nights I was like wow man
you're gonna go home you're gonna have a
glass of red wine and work on your [ __ ]
it's really weird how many nights you'll
walk off at the cellar and go I [ __ ]
skank itness i'll walk upstairs
sometimes how does how does this happen
to you all the time tell me all the
times Lee all the time killing it there
all the time I like the apps but really
all the time and you've been doing how
long 26 years so 12 26 years in you
leave some nights going like this isn't
for me we had a conversation I'd like to
hear that month we had a conversation
the night about like how long does it
take you is like Damien lemon and Mike
yard and a bunch of us how long does it
take you to feel like you really know
what you're doing and it's like on a
paper like unit 22 years you know you
know what you're doing but like after a
bad set it doesn't feel like you know
what you're doing you're like I couldn't
get them I don't know what I'm doing is
if I knew what I was doing I would have
gotten them and I couldn't so this year
the cellar is great because they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] who's on stage if
you're not what they want at that moment
they don't necessarily scream at you but
you know like I'm [ __ ] the bed part of
that is because even like somebody like
you who's well known well who's known in
the u.s. well yeah not in France we
don't know this guy
no is it we have no idea but like the
seller doesn't necessarily like that
post on their website but the audience
for the seller is not necessarily like
oh we're coming to see this comedian
though they just go and say oh there's
there's good comedy that they're hoping
for Jerry or Louie right now they know
that those guys should want for him we
don't know when he performs her they
have no idea they have no idea I just
kind of come in yeah yeah I don't put my
name on the list my house I'm not there
is Emmys Mustapha there wasn't Mustafa
who worked there oh really yeah he was
he was my favorite door guy ever
he was a [ __ ] he would he would
actually just uh if anybody was talking
he would walk over go
shut the [ __ ] up and throw them out here
squared legendary for throwing people
out by them by the way that that's great
you know when you perform when you try
things you don't you don't want your
your material to go on on the internet
an hour after that and also it's not a
good atmosphere when they do that so
yeah I like it but I like it one day
they stay you know they're rude with
people and like don't film don't do this
in France it's so I mean they do it and
they film they do anything yeah you
can't yell you don't really yell at the
audience in France and yeah a little bit
I mean you know it's again I think
there's this thing to improvise and
crowd work you have to come up with good
things but yes if you go with the easy
and the cheap things we are all done so
many things and try things with the
crowd but you need to be very point you
I don't know the word but you know
precise yes it's like doing jokes on
Trump right now Ryan come on guys you
have to come up with the very funny joke
about surgeries everything has been done
try saying this stupid thing those
stupid and is it now come up with crazy
thing the opposite I don't know do
something creative right I'm kind of
tired of those jokes like Oh stupid is
not as no okay it's it is the same point
of view because you've heard it from
everybody when the pointing like when as
soon as somebody opens their mouth of
you know exactly what yeah by the way
maybe that's a premise for something
maybe I said it just like that but maybe
I could work on something like I knew
Trump was gonna be elected that's why I
moved was about to say I think that's
funny when you said that yeah and I was
like there's one there's not that many
funny Trump jokes left but that was yeah
you know I three I think I got did you
do any political stuff little not a lot
mine I'm in France more obviously but
right not not yet not not nothing I feel
like you know like like with the Daily
Show now like that's what has hindered
Trevor Noah is that you know you
criticize American politics which is
what the show was always about but
people don't necessarily want to see
American politics get criticized by
someone with an accent yeah it really
does [ __ ] people get really annoys at
a tip that you're giving me right now
well you said you don't do that I don't
uh but if you did you'd never do
I never do that rock America is great
and the opportunity for me as a freshman
Jew to be able to perform every night in
that wonderful country after all the
success world I can do the army i
anything you want yeah it is funny when
guys come over and Pollock the political
stuff is great for some guys are [ __ ]
like they just stand there and harp on
it for like 20 minutes so funny just to
watch the kragle is something that I ask
to every comedians I I was very
surprised so those guys when they go on
stage at the cellar
do you know before you said exactly what
you're gonna do I have an idea but I
like to try to work out if I'm doing an
hour the order not an hour like I said
15 minutes you go on well if I'm doing
it for an hour on the road I'll pull a
few minutes out and try to work on it so
some nights I know I'm working on the
opening so I know I'm going to open but
no a lot of times I don't it's very
boring just to do the first 10 minutes
in a row of my road act nobody want to
do that so I try to mix up things that
need work it's like you know I just pull
out little pieces that I think need a
line fixed I try them there makes sense
yeah yeah makes sense yeah it gets too
boring applying right half the time
isn't enjoying what I'm doing so my card
switch gears that's dirty
but with the language I have to do this
boring thing and I know exactly what I'm
gonna do boom boom boom number one two
three four sometimes I said oh you kind
of have to choreograph what you're doing
yes yeah maybe in one year from now with
the English it's gonna be but you do an
hour on the road so yeah like if you're
starting in Denver you do he's doing
Carnegie Hall February 11th so if you're
doing those are you doing them in
English and partially French are all
under not all in English all English and
I know because I there there are a lot
of expats from not only from France from
you know Morocco because my I was born
in Morocco Morocco Algeria Lebanese
people a lot of expats immigrants they
come to see my shows I put a few things
accents references not a lot but the
show is mainly in English obviously yes
so I've never been if I want to go to
Paris I never want you to do I always
think they're gonna hate Americans so I
never go no that's not truly just on the
studio you mean like it as far as
performing or there you know activism I
know so you think you're gonna be
walking on the street and the the
Parisians are gonna hate you no but I've
just heard that in like in restaurants
that they don't like about on you it's
no no no but as one street I'll tell you
it's a logical Boulevard they let me
reek no but a lot of American comedians
come now to France and it's a good thing
that American get to travel and I think
Louie CK came last summer I heard Jim
Gaffigan wants to come to do a stand-up
a lot of you know you should come you
should come to Paris I also said - no
I'm the Comedy Cellar coming to our
owner we should do this thing they do
now for fashion for clubs pop-ups right
yeah sure sure we should do pop-up
Comedy Cellar
in Paris Berlin television cool idea it
would be cool and so you bring a bunch
of comics they know each other they're
always working together the seller and
then boom we do the show and Comedy
Cellar has become a brand especially cuz
after like after Louie and after all
these different things that went all
over the world people know I want to do
this in Paris like the pop-up Comedy
Cellar and bring like five six comics
and have like a week or on a 3-4 days in
a club and that would be the Comedy
Cellar Paris we do it on the road but
not take now I don't want to get
enormous permission I'd want to do it
I'd want to use the name on the road
yeah that's that that probably would
work but you know the the comedy sounds
words it's kind of become like The
Improv used to be like years ago like
with The Improv was the reference like
where you land for el NiO just
everywhere the New York improv was that
was the movie reference for comedy and
now it seems like it's the cellar yeah
problem so many years ago yeah yeah yeah
it's the place so I have you have you
gotten into spots here where people
don't really know who you are and then
they do something like check your
Twitter account or something and realize
like oh yes I got this every day but
those spots are everywhere yes that's
the whole new watches people like kind
of shift in their behavior
yeah as they realize like oh yeah I
should know who this is yeah and I don't
like it
you don't know because I'm as soon as I
land here in New York City I kind of
relax and you know I you know I see
people they it's natural it's it's it's
not fake I like it and you know it's
it's cool yeah obviously when you
someone asked you okay I'm gonna follow
you on twitter
he sees I have 6.5 millions like who
what the [ __ ] and he's a you know he's
got a lot he's got six point seven
million oh yeah she just missed $200,000
I thought that's because of this show
we're doing right now we just got two
hundred thousand guys that's a lot yeah
but it's that's funny to be so damaged
it's like oh yeah be so famous that you
want to just kind of relax and come to
New York and blend in and just build
that's that's a really interesting are
you worried though what if what if you
become very famous in America no it's
gonna be terrible now everybody's gonna
bother you it's gonna be nightmare yeah
no I'm good like this I'm not looking
for that I'm just want to work on my act
I want to do stand-up I want to do no no
I I don't know we'll see um it seems
like everything's coming together right
now because like Jim just said you have
the tour coming up you're going to tour
pretty much all through January yeah and
then end the tour at Carnegie Hall but
you've also moved here and you got a
Netflix special yeah coming out on the
24th of January so like you talked about
like the the the people who are here
that know you from other countries from
Paris from Morocco from whatever if they
show up to Carnegie Hall are they going
to be disappointed that you're speaking
in English oh no no no they know exactly
what I'm doing and that's funny because
but but it's interesting what you're
mentioning right now because I've done
shows in French in the past in America
hmm and I would put some English in my
shows and experts were like oh don't
speak English it was shock no no and I
even have a joke about that at the
opening of my shows I say bonsoir in
France and then I say that's it for
French yeah and said come on French
people I'm trying to work on the new
project but I have jokes about it they
know it's in English and the interesting
thing they're kind of supportive for
this project for me yet my fans from
other countries no no it's um it's fun
it's fun comics respect it just because
the balls it tastes yeah to say I'm
gonna leave this place where I'm doing
you know [ __ ] a Friday Saturday shows
in an arena and come here and just kind
of build it's like yeah that's such an
artistic thing to do and it's not for
money it's you know giving up a personal
challenge really last week was really
really strange funny bizarre I really
lik
I performed in bassy which is like
Madison Square Garden here it was 12,000
people on Saturday night then I flew and
Sunday and I flew here in two nights on
to night eight nights by eight nights a
night but did today I said I guess a
concert ticket I should arrive right
yeah yeah I tickets to watch I can brag
I can brag a little bit to to this
morning yeah I did eight nights and then
I flew on the Monday to New York uh-huh
and I jumped in a cab and I went to the
cellar and I did a set in front of 100
people right you're trying to win him
over just not sure like they don't love
me yes I want to earn and this it's
really interesting I was so into I know
it's it's a any note comedy we are crazy
last night I was saying to this to Ryan
Hamilton who's a good friend great comic
and I see him every night and I was
watching people's that we are crazy we
are crazy we're doing a crazy job every
day starting over every day asking
worrying the doubt and coming back and
cried oh no that says do you feel like I
start over every day yeah yeah really
that's great that is crazy
you never feel really good about your so
like you can feel great about yourself
and then it's one [ __ ] set you're like
oh yeah they're right I'm garbage yep
just confirms do you kind of knowing
that if you have a good set is there
something in you that stops you from
fully enjoying it because you know
tomorrow it might not be good hmm I
enjoy a good set you don't you you can
enjoy you yeah it feels good I know it
was good and they feel great yeah okay
that's our like like when we're doing
the show even if we have a good what
eventually when we have a good I mean
we're never happy to be honest because I
enjoy a good set when it's the last one
yeah but also I'm pumped on them like I
want to do another one right and I also
I don't know that's we don't know we
don't know what we want right yeah if
it's one day you sugar there's no one -
people - laughs we want girls sitting
next to us at the club yeah so I would
imagine though for you like you don't
need to be famous again America doesn't
you're finally to be here dead but
yeah I don't need to be with you this
morning I don't need the took me 45
minutes out of town the guy downstairs I
don't even know my name is butchered my
name with me twice for my ID I come and
I see this guy I can see for free every
time it really is like a Norton then
this is a crazy part
this whole experience of the morning and
doing all that that's the great ID twice
now in France if that happened they know
you you wouldn't have a show now I mean
you know I just did a hundred thousand
people and then went back on the cellar
you there's something very funny and I
think it's dangerous also when I come
home when I get there in Paris at the
airport iceworm not exaggerating just to
make make up the I give my passport to
the customs almost nine times out of ten
they go like huh it's okay it's okay
what that's my passport I'm dumped right
no we know it's okay we know we know now
are you single you date different women
um I'm okay I didn't understand the
dating process in America but dating is
I see different woman every yeah is
dating is dating yeah yeah I'm single
that's right that's a fancy though
that's it you know being single in New
York City is it great Wow
are you single yeah but not for the same
reasons you are I'm not single because I
have my pick of amazing women I'm just I
can't get anybody to go for it yeah
that's pretty much it yeah you wanna
know how a single door is gonna go back
on door is gonna be you're not a single
Jim is no tell me he told me what he did
last night which is he went to a
restaurant by himself and brought a
newspaper and read it with his cell
phone flash him the lady's dim I'm older
I had my [ __ ] iPhone I'm reading my
newspaper with my iPhone that's single
that's only that is setting the
chameleon that's a comedian life you
know what I did yesterday what I stayed
at home the whole day waiting for my set
at night that's it that's crazy
nothing out nothing else writing
correcting things trying not to do
something else because maybe it's gonna
distract sidetrack me really very little
scared of maybe not be crazy too cold in
bed writing and waiting and how long
ever said are you doing like how long
ever said did you feel any right what do
you mean 15 minutes it's like how long
would
set yeah first everyone know I like yeah
and I do three four depends okay and you
just sit there waiting yeah and last
night there was also that's a new
experience for me because I'm doing
sometimes talk shows whatever and they
come and they want to see the set before
and they want the script and they want
the video I it's new to me yeah I mean
in Paris is someone said to me give me
your scripts it what what right give me
your ID no I mean this is but it's okay
you you need to be humble so this girl
came last night from Colbert because I'm
gonna be doing that show next week and I
gave my script video sound they came see
it live twice they said are we gonna
come back but it's good I'm working but
it's gotta be almost like a goof to you
at this point like that's gotta be kind
of funny goof like the jokes I don't
know like it's kind of ridiculous you're
like you know how much I you say to do
Colbert okay you don't I wanted to go I
know you want to but you don't need it
but you don't need to prove to any talk
show I don't want to prove myself a
million on Twitter yeah but I want to be
on the talk show in America right with
that yeah it was funny how they oh and
this all shows do it they overly prepare
you for stuff they obsess over every
word and every joke and it's like let
the natural let it but the guy's funny
and you see a set thing you already is
funny then you let him just go out and
do it six minutes whatever it's a min
live it's taped like you know worst-case
scenario I think sometimes they should
let it go a little bit every talk shows
not not only in America everywhere
everywhere TV are you know they're
stressed or very so I think it's good if
they let go but you know I would say yes
to anything right now I'm not in a
position where obviously you're here
yeah yes I here for now he won't come up
into the show so tell me what's going on
here I so many little houses here it's
like a massage thing yeah there's a lot
of cabin right yeah that's it that's how
we call a lot of places to go in and get
your talk so yeah which basically every
every radio station you could imagine is
up here the hip hop stations next door
Entertainment Weekly's on that side when
I listen all the time because I'm a very
big Frank Sinatra plan and there's a one
called simply serious on Sinatra that's
it I mean you don't even want to like
they do all the seriously Sinatra
in like a little like closet down the
hall it's really not very striking it's
tiny you don't want to it's not a
pre-recorded wood things now Sinatra
thing is like people hanging out with
champagne not no cigar it's all fake no
guy would sound affectionate I know now
this shows everyday yeah our shows every
day if then you were here every day yeah
Monday through Friday 8:00 to 11:00 okay
yeah every morning that's why I go on
early at the cellar when I show up
because it's just I have to give up yeah
what are you yeah you can now go out
really after your sets yeah try not to
I'm just
every now and the word it where do you
live I'm on on the east side in the 20s
okay okay
swimming head were you I live in the
Tribeca oh you are yeah is it isn't your
like cuz you're talking before about
like women like changing their vibe that
woman in LA who totally changed her vibe
after you saw she saw you by the way do
you hook up with her people yeah oh yeah
well worth it well done yeah yeah I
would think that the accent does enough
to get the job done more often than not
doesn't you know I I did more than that
I'm I used to signed up on the dating
app tinder know another one very very
reinder Raja right right yeah right why
is a good one I strike out [ __ ]
horribly on Rahman Riya and I literally
I'm like I said nothing
what do you mean nothing I talked to
them but they know they Google me and
I'm finished that's happened me a bunch
of time series and prom he's very very
open about it stories no Jim listen I
have the opposite yeah
they Google me and then they call me
right see we play him its yong-chol to
him like oh this guy's trash garbage he
likes to tell stories about what he does
in his personal life and they come back
they come back to haunt em you know I
know the stories I know yeah - got the
hottest girls that when you go to riot
cuz you have to be mean you know based
on picture you never met any of them no
I think I met wine and we actually had a
nice date we went out I'd wanted to date
her for a while during the paper what
size did you bring the newspaper I did
not it was it was a nice little detail
but we're not one but wait I I do that
really often I go and have dinner but
just me alone by myself that's okay you
don't do no I don't mind that but
the news like this bring the newspaper
in the flats dinnertime
that's really bad you have to read the
paper it's very dim they have it there
move light mood lighting for the yeah
buddy night all by yourself you don't go
in a very demon and ambiance thing
atmosphere like that right there's no
reason for it romantic
he wanted the romantic night did yo you
wanted a romance romance himself took
myself out yeah it was nice masturbation
romance the autorun man he went home he
lit some candles yeah then he start
jerking off yeah the memory of my
present little bit raw colet's yeah but
I got to me me some chocolate yeah
little scarf I will say this one of the
hottest girls I've ever seen yeah like
this was with you at the Comedy Cellar
one real you might have just been
friends I don't know she was but last
night no no this is a couple months ago
Oh Sunday I was never mean Saturday
different girl every night it was she
was [ __ ] stunning but he didn't say
anything because he doesn't talk to
people at the cellar gym he's very
socially awkward I his he doesn't want
to talk to be nice I talked to the guy
sitting I'm Ron he runs he goes on stage
and he runs he I've been works very fast
I've been to parties with him so very
socially awkward yeah very awkward
doesn't talk to people
mmm-hmm doesn't he's a smart is an
interesting character but he likes to
remain a mystery no I never think people
want to talk to me so I sit down I set
the table all the time and I never want
to bother people imposing myself really
yeah so I just this is not what we think
when we see you oh yeah no what do you
think I love oh look how much they saw
her I think he doesn't want to talk to
us right he's right too much in his
thing and he has so many things to do
and is no no and then he ends up alone
in the little deem yeah restaurant but I
was in a comedians table I always sit at
the comics table I don't sit there yes
yeah that's sometimes I'm always there
it's like if I got a little nervous when
I sit there do you it's just you know
it's you know I don't know they know who
the [ __ ] you are no it's just it the
language it goes so far no yeah yeah
I prepared what I'm doing right now I
prepared it the whole night let's all
scripted what I asked out here that's
all script we've our producers asked you
for a script before you came in there's
the questions we need your answer this
one's not good we're gonna tease Jim for
being alone
and Jody and I think hey I think that
God is taking full advantage of of the
women here in in America I think that is
I think you're doing very well with
women this woman is right there what
about you married your marriage he's
doing really well his wife has made a
terrible choice he's doing she's smoking
yes I'm married she's pregnant the whole
thing it's over subscribe she was
pregnant before before we got married I
thought yeah yeah I met her she is
pregnant I met her yeah no I am seventy
one of his jokes we're going on his I
inseminated my wife yeah I did I did I
impregnated her yeah and that's my
listening yeah yeah but I divorced yeah
but you got a dad now yeah I'm married
for real
Wow yeah so I'm not single I know Carol
is gonna get married in a few months
right you are yeah Kerala works with me
she's a she's history she yeah she's my
my left hand okay left arm sometimes my
right hand no that's strange she said he
come out you Dima Dima Dima - whoa he'd
rescue me he proposed so he proposed and
then he said we're gonna get married in
two years from now what do you think
about that well I I would've said ten
two years is okay though it's a nice
long I think I think I did a year in
nine months I think it did mean pretty
close to do you for the year nine months
it's like something you want energy in
you're in love anyone but you got a plan
you got a in the timing got it'll do a
whole bunch of stuff yeah it really
takes a lot to get married you know it's
invite people you have to plan the whole
event you have to do there's a lot to do
right so you give up your marriage
I have two kids but I've never been but
she's worried if she's got to do
everything for you what do you mean but
she's your right hand in your left hand
everything that says you got yeah so
she's got to sit there and like when I
have time I'll try to plan a wedding
who's gonna take two years with dad's
schedule I'm just a little I don't like
people who I work with when they get
married and all that because they got an
outside light you don't lay a hand like
I don't like that yeah I don't like that
there's enough going on with get her own
place apartment yeah so she where's your
priorities boyfriend's days you said you
were
working with me see you guys you so now
do you know when you have an assistant
do they know they know so much about
your personal life that's what always
scares me they don't have one no why
because it's just oh boy no you're not
the assistant type I don't know I
promise you every yeah we like to give
you the stuffing John system yeah yeah
yeah yeah it'd be a fun job it's just
another hazmat suit
it scares me too uh I don't know why I
actually haven't done I probably should
kid there's so many things that I [ __ ]
up and forget like it ties it's like I
always felt like I'm not at that point
my career where I need one but there's
just a lot of things I make mistakes
with it I probably should you know just
to just for so I don't [ __ ] things up it
helps to have them but the girl I don't
know I don't want to bother you and your
whether like I don't [ __ ] with people in
there with a girl cuz I want to annoy
them or be annoying or like you know oh
I remember
months ago you know dad is just like I
know her and I'm over no just no no no I
mean respect the woman that's what I
need a nice French girl is that what
you're looking for oh I can't oh yeah
you think you can hook that up yeah yeah
really I bet you can just should give me
just a few jokes in English okay that's
it train jokes for girls that make sense
oh boy would she be disappointed also
you'll notice you unfollow you on
Twitter like what that [ __ ] guy was
weird
terrible was this guy we'll listen we're
out of time that's the show is over
that's the show that's the show that's a
good time I'm happy it's experience the
whole thing yeah god is a really really
funny stand-up yeah I have seen you on
stage and you're and you're really good
yeah it'll be at Gotham on Wednesday
okay so you're in New York go to Gotham
comedy club this Wednesday and then the
oh my GAD US tour begins January 19th in
Denver Colorado and it wraps up February
11th at Carnegie Hall tickets are
available at god LM la L managed not el
mal eh dad comedians very easy to find
yes yeah it should be gag comedian calm
never been to Denver how is Denver
awesome yeah really awesome yeah it's a
great crowds the elevation is 5,000 feet
so everybody's like this
they smoke pot they're modified they're
making crowds oh it's legal in Denver so
a lot of pot are you doing the Comedy
Works uh no I don't know yeah theater
yeah okay yeah it's a great great place
you'll be awesome excellent there and
then he's wrapping up February 11th at
Carnegie Hall so it's a short tour a lot
of great rooms and gets a really funny
act I love you so much I am almost every
weekend so messy merci beaucoup and
grass yes yes yeah yes yes yeah okay
well okay
Schatzi sure and uh yes a Google gadna
find out all about him if you don't
already know and you could follow my
Twitter he's got like six point seven
million he won't notice you he's not
gonna notice notice you he's not gonna
answer your [ __ ] I think I'm gonna
come back on that show I want to come
back yeah coming yoga just come five
minutes and say hi everyone
come back in any time you're good time
every time I come back with a different
girl I would like that oh yes a lot oh
yes god yeah heavy [ __ ] dude she was she
was so pretty she was depressed okay I
have an idea
yeah what do you think about that hey oh
I have that's the Travis dog that's
Travis dog that's Travis no sorry I it's
fine I'm not here to be no I mean I'm
sorry I then are you just sorry because
I'm yeah cuz he's Travis dog who are you
I'm gay I'm gay I'm Travis Dunn you lost
your train of thought you're gonna bring
some French girls here and then you know
I have an idea
come on how do you see if we bleak
segment a segment segment yes yeah we
could okay this is my idea you you tell
me maybe can you do a meeting with
production or everything
Travis targets the production so this is
the meeting sometimes I show up and we
do this five minutes with a French girl
I bring your friends girl mm-hmm I don't
know why mm-hmm just bring this girl I'm
sure and we have a conversation I know
the bit we could do
what's the bit I give her oral sex and
she tells me if I'm good at it that's my
a great that's a good work I just I just
I've just been unfollowed by two
50,000 a people in France if you want to
bring a French girl up here to introduce
her to Jim I would love that man that
would be so fun it'd be hilarious
let's let's do it okay let's do this one
day I come figured out what do - oh I'm
so bad at that - no it's great okay
great it'll be fun the hook up the hook
up we say look up yeah yeah up Jim with
a French girl okay Travis you will
prepare a little little jingle or
something course French music with the
accordion voice hook up moment
yeah okay that's they go oh recording
done yeah thank you so much for having
me thank you oh wow there's us I'll be
at the Tara time Music Hall New Year's
Eve that's my last show of the tour and
uh thank you to everybody who's been
coming out to these [ __ ] warm-up shows
it's been an amazing last month